all right so last video I showed you
guys this really crazy fact we have our
usual setup here for this constrained
optimization situation we have a
function we want to maximize which I'm
thinking of as revenues for some company
a constraint which I'm thinking of as
some kind of budget for that company and
as you know if you've gotten to this
video one way to solve this constrained
optimization problem is to define this
function here the Lagrangian which
involves taking this function that
you're trying to maximize in this case
the revenue and subtracting a new
variable lambda what's called the
Lagrange multiplier times this quantity
which is the budget function
you know however much you spend as a
function of your input parameters minus
the budget itself which you might think
of as you know $10,000 in our example so
that's all the usual set up and the
crazy fact which I just declared is that
when you set this gradient equal to zero
and you find some solution and there
will be three variables in this solution
H star s star and lambda star that this
lambda star is not meaningless it's not
just a proportionality constant between
these gradient vectors but it will
actually tell you how much the maximum
possible revenue changes as a function
of your budget and the way to start
writing all of that in formulas would be
to make explicit the fact that if you
consider this value you know the $10,000
that is your budget which I'm calling be
a variable and not a constant then you
have to acknowledge that H star and s
star are dependent on B right it's a
very implicit relationship something
that's kind of hard to think about it
first because as you change B it changes
what the Lagrangian is which is going to
change where it's gradient equals zero
which changes what H star s star and
lambda star are but in principle they
are some function of that budget of B
and the maximum possible revenue is
whatever you get when you just plug in
that solution to your function R and the
claim I made that I just pulled out of
the Hat is that lambda star the lambda
value that comes packaged in with these
two when you set the gradient of the
lagrangian equal to zero equals the
derivative of this maximum value thought
of as a function of B maybe I should
emphasize that you know we're thinking
of this maximum value as a function of B
with respect to B so that's kind of a
mouthful it takes a lot just to even
phrase what's going on but in the
context of an economic example it has a
very clear precise meaning which is if
you increase your budget by a dollar
right if you increase it from ten
thousand dollars to ten thousand and $1
you're wondering for that tiny change in
budget that tiny DB what is the ratio of
the resulting change in revenue so in a
sense this lambda star tells you for
every dollar that you increase the
budget how much can your revenue
increase if you're always maximizing it
so why on earth is this true right this
just seems like it comes out of nowhere
well there are a couple clever
observations that go into proving this
the first the first is to notice what
happens if we evaluate this Lagrangian
function itself at this critical point
when you input H star s star and lambda
star and remember the way that these
guys are defined is that you look at all
of the values where the gradient of the
lagrangian equals the zero vector and
then if you get multiple options you
know sometimes when you set the gradient
equal to zero you get multiple solutions
and whichever one maximizes our that is
H star s star lambda star so now I'm
just asking if you plug that naught into
the gradient of the Lagrangian but to
the Lagrangian itself what do you get
well you're going to get we just look at
its definition up here are evaluated at
H star and s star right and we subtract
off lambda star times B of H star s star
minus the constant that is your budget
you know something you might think of as
as $10,000 whatever you said little B
equal to okay grant you might say why
why does this tell us anything you're
just plugging in stars instead of the
usual variables but the key is that if
you plug in H star and s star this value
has to equal zero
because H star and s star have to
satisfy the constraint remember one of
the cool parts about this lagrangian
function as a whole is that when you
take its partial derivative with respect
to lambda all that's left is this
constraint function minus the constraint
portion when you set the gradient of the
Lagrangian equal to the zero vector one
component of that is to set the partial
derivative with respect to lambda equal
to zero and if you remember from the
Lagrangian video all that really boils
down to is the fact that the constraint
holds right which would be your budget
achieves $10,000 when you plug in the
appropriate H star and s star to this
value you are hitting this constrained
amount of money that you can spend so by
virtue of how H star and s star are
defined the fact that they are solutions
to the constrained optimization problem
means this whole portion goes to zero so
we can just kind of cancel all that out
and what's left what's left here is the
maximum possible revenue right so
evidently when you evaluate the
lagrangian at this critical point at h
star s star and lambda star it equals m
star it equals the maximum possible
value for the function you're trying to
maximize so ultimately what we want is
to understand how that maximum value
changes when you consider it a function
of the budget so evidently what we can
look for is to just ask how the
Lagrangian changes as you consider it a
function of the budget now this is an
interesting thing to observe because if
we just look up at the definition of the
Lagrangian if you just look at this
formula if I told you to take the
derivative of this with respect to
little B right you know how much does
this change with respect to little B you
would notice that this goes to zero it
doesn't have a little B this would also
go to zero and all you'd be left with
would be negative lambda times negative
B and the derivative of that with
respect to B would be lambda so you
might say oh yeah of course of course
this the derivative of that Lagrangian
with respect to B once we work it all
out the only term that was left there
was the lambda and that's compelling but
ultimately it's not entirely right that
overlooks the fact that L
is not actually defined as a function of
B when we define that the Lagrangian we
were considering B to be a constant so
if you really want to consider this to
be a function that involves B the way we
should write it and I'll go ahead and
erase this guy the way we should write
this Lagrangian is to say you're a
function of H star which itself is
dependent on B and s star which is also
a function of B right as soon as we
start considering be a variable and not
a constant we have to acknowledge that
this critical point H star s star and
lambda star depends on the value of B so
likewise that lambda star lambda star is
also going to be a function of B and
then we can consider as a fourth
variable right so we're adding on yet
another variable to this function the
value of B itself the value of B itself
here so now when we want to know what is
the value of the Lagrangian at the
critical point H star s star lambda star
as a function of B all right so that can
be kind of confusing what you basically
have is this function that only really
depends on one value right it only
depends on B but it kind of goes through
a for variable function and so just to
make it explicit this would equal the
value of R as a function of H star and s
star and each one of those is a function
of little B right so this term is saying
what's your revenue evaluated on the
maximizing H and s for the given budget
and then you subtract off lambda star so
here I should probably I'm not gonna
have room here am I so what you subtract
off minus lambda star at
B of H star and s star but each of these
guys is also a function of little B
little B minus little B right so you
have this large kind of complicated
multivariable function it's defined in
terms of H stars and s stars which are
themselves very implicit right we just
say by definition these are whatever
values make the gradient of L equal 0 so
very hard to think about what that means
concretely but all of this is really
just dependent on the single value
little B and from here if we want to
evaluate the derivative of L we want to
evaluate the derivative of this
Lagrangian with respect to little B
which is really the only thing it
depends on it's just via all of these
other variables we use the multivariable
chain rule and at this point if you
don't know the multivariable chain rule
I have a video on that definitely pause
go take a look make sure that it all
makes sense but right here I'm just
going to be assuming that you know what
the multivariable chain rule is so what
it is is we take the partial we're going
to look at the partial derivatives with
respect to all four of these inputs so
we'll start with the partial derivative
of L with respect to H star with respect
to H star and we're going to multiply
that by the derivative of H star with
respect to B and this might seem like a
very hard thing to think about like how
do we know how H star changes as B
changes but don't worry about it you'll
see something magic happen in just a
moment and then we add in partial
derivative of L with respect to that
second variable s star with respect to
whatever the second variable is x the
derivative of s star with respect to B
you can see how you really need to know
what the multivariable chain rule is
right this would all seem kind of out of
the blue so what we now add in is the
partial to
Rivet --iv of L with respect to that
lambda star with respect to lambda star
x the derivative of lambda star with
respect to little b and then finally
finally we take the partial derivative
of this Lagrangian with respect to that
little B which we're now considering a
variable in there right we're no longer
considering that be a constant x well
something kind of silly the derivative
of B with respect to itself so now if
you're thinking that this is going to be
horrifying to compute I can understand
where you're coming from you have to
know the derivative of lambda star with
respect to B you have to somehow
intimately be familiar with how this
lambda star changes as you change B and
like I said that's such an implicit
relationship right we just said that
lambda star is by definition whatever
the solution to this gradient equation
is so somehow you're supposed to know
how that changes when you when you
slightly alter B over here well you
don't really have to worry about things
because by definition H star s star and
lambda star are whatever values make the
gradient of L equal to 0 but if you
think about that what does it mean for
the gradient of L to equal the 0 vector
well what it means is that when you take
its derivative with respect to that
first variable H star it equals 0 when
you take its derivative with respect to
the second variable that equals 0 as
well and with respect to this third
variable that's going to equal 0 by
definition H star s star and lambda star
are whatever values make it the case so
that when you plug them in the partial
derivative of the Lagrangian with
respect to any one of those variables
equals 0 so we don't even have to worry
about most of this equation the only
part that matters here is the partial
derivative of L with respect to B that
we're now considering a variable x well
what's DB DB and how what is the rate of
change of a variable with respect to
itself it's 1 it is 1 so all of this
stuff this
entire multivariable chain rule boils
down to a single innocent-looking factor
which is the partial derivative of L
partial derivative of L with respect to
little B and now there's something very
subtle here right because this might
seem obvious I'm saying the derivative
of L with respect to B equals the
derivative of L with respect to B but
maybe I should give a different notation
here right because here when I'm taking
the derivative really I'm considering L
as a single variable function right I'm
considering not what happens as you can
freely change all four of these
variables three of them are locked into
place by B so maybe I should really give
that a different name I should call that
L star L star is a single variable
function whereas this L is a multi
variable function this is the function
where you can freely change the values
of H and s and lambda and B as you put
them in so if we kind of scroll up to
look at its definition which I've
written all over I guess here let me
actually rewrite its definition right I
think that'll be useful I'm going to
rewrite that l if I consider it as a for
variable function of H s lambda and B
that what that equals is are evaluated H
and s minus lambda multiplied by this
constraint function B evaluated at H and
s minus little B and this is now when
I'm considering little B to be a
variable so this is the Lagrangian when
you consider all four of these to be
freely changing as you want whereas the
thing up here that I'm considering a
single variable function has three of
its inputs locked into place so
effectively it's just a single variable
function with respect to B so it's
actually quite miraculous that the
single variable derivative of that L
nearby should L star with respect to B
ends up being the same as the partial
derivative of L this L where you're free
to change all the variables that these
should be the same usually in any usual
circumstance all of these other terms
would have come into play somehow
but what's special here is that by the
definition of this L star the specific
way in which these H star s star and
lambda stars are locked into place
happens to be one in which all of these
partial derivatives go to zero so that's
pretty subtle and I think it's quite
clever and what it leaves us with is
that we just have to evaluate this
partial derivative which is quite simple
because we look down here and you say
what's the partial derivative of L with
respect to B well
this R has no B's in it so don't need to
care about that this term over here it's
partial derivative is negative one right
just because there's a B here and that's
multiplied by the constant lambda so
that all just equals lambda but if we're
in the situation where lambda is locked
into place as a function of little B
then we'd write lambda star as a
function of little B right so if that
feels a little notationally confusing
I'm right there with you but the
important part here the important thing
to remember is that we just started
considering B as a variable right and we
were looking at the H star s star and
lambda star as they depended on that
variable we made the observation that
the Lagrangian evaluated at that
critical point equals the revenue
evaluated at that critical point the
rest of the stuff just cancels out so if
you want to know the derivative of M
star the maximizing revenue with respect
to the budget you know how much does
your maximum revenue change for tiny
changes in your budget that's the same
as looking at the derivative of the
Lagrangian with respect to the budget so
long as you're considering it only on
values H star s star lambda star that
our critical points of the Lagrangian
and all of that really nicely boils down
to just taking a simple partial
derivative that gives us the relation we
want